[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend sinnlos nicht
nachvollziehbar und zu reichen das ist
aus den Verhandlungskreisen zwischen der
Deutschen Bahn und der Gewerkschaft EVG
zu hören verhärtete Fronten nennt sich
das wohl dabei hatte die Bahnen einem
dritten Angebot noch mal deutlich
nachgebessert der EVG geht das aber
nicht weit genug womit sie nun heute
droht sie ahnen schon sind neue Streiks
wie schon im März und April auch da
hatte die Gewerkschaft bundesweit dem
Bahnverkehr ihr lahmgelegt die Bahn
wiederum hat wegen Sturheit auf der
anderen Seite die Verhandlungen
lahmgelegt Peter Wagner
es ist jede Menge Kommunikation nötig zu
jeder Sekunde um die Deutsche Bahn am
Fahren zu halten im täglichen Betrieb
gelingt das ziemlich gut die Züge rollen
auch wenn es mit der Pünktlichkeit
harpert die Kommunikation untereinander
im Tarifkonflikt spottet mittlerweile
jeder Beschreibung erst ließ die
Gewerkschaft hoffnungskeime sprießen
nach dem stark verbesserten Angebot der
Arbeitgeber und heute alle Signale
wieder auf Rot ein einziges Schuld Ping
Pong via Pressekonferenzen die EVG hat
das pauschal abgelehnt aber zu einem
Angebot ja und Arm zu sagen ist nicht
Wesen einer Tarifverhandlung und hat
keinen Millimeter signalisiert sich auf
den Kompromiss zu bewegen zu wollen er
selber hat jegliches Gespräch abgelehnt
aber jetzt ist die EVG im Zug wir sind
verhandlungsbereit wenn das Signal kommt
selbstverständlich sind wir auch bereit
dann wieder zu sprechen und zu
verhandeln da fliegen die Funken das
klingt nach mehr als eine
Missverständnis grob skizziert liegt
dieses Angebot auf dem Tisch acht bis
zwölf Prozent mehr Lohn gestaffelt nach
Einkommen Plus
inflationsausgleichsprämie von 2850 Euro
für alle verteilt auf 24 Monate Laufzeit
die EVG fordert deutlich mehr 12 Prozent
für alle eine Mindestbetrag von 650 Euro
für alle bei 12 Monaten Laufzeit das
würde die Bahn 2,4 Milliarden Euro im
Jahr kosten das eigene Angebot bzw mit
1,4 Milliarden Volumen im Jahr was tun
wenn zwei Parteien nicht mehr
weiterkommen wenn alles festgefahren
scheint erfahrene Mediatoren kennen
solche Situationen dazu gehört die
Bereitschaft sich auf den Stuhl des
anderen einmal zu setzen es gehört auch
die Bereitschaft dazu nicht unbedingt
das erreichen zu wollen
was man sich vorgestellt hat weitere
unbedingt die Voraussetzungen ist dass
man fair miteinander umgeht dass man
alle Dinge offenlegt die für eine
Entscheidung wichtig sind ein vielleicht
ausschlaggebender Punkt denn es geht der
EVG auch um die Behauptung ihrer
gewerkschaftsmacht gegenüber der anderen
streitbaren Truppe im Bahnkonzern
beselskis Lokführer Gewerkschaft GDL
hatte mit ihrer kompromisslosen Linie
viele Mitglieder gewonnen da gibt es was
nachzuholen hätte eine Mediation den
Erfolgsaussichten es gibt da sehr gute
Beispiele der Westfälische Frieden nach
dem 30-jährigen Krieg der ist zustande
gekommen durch die Tätigkeit eines
Mediators
da bleibt doch noch Hoffnung auch wenn
sich niemand einen 30-jährigen Tarif
Streit bei der Bahn wirklich wünschen
mag
ein Schlagabtausch der anderen Art
spielt sich aktuell auf diplomatischer
Ebene zwischen Russland und Deutschland
ab nachdem der Kreml verkündet hatte das
hunderte Mitarbeiter deutscher
Institutionen und Diplomaten im Juni
ausgewiesen werden hat heute das
Auswärtige Amt die Schließung von vier
von fünf russischen Konsulaten in
Deutschland verkündet das alles sind
Konsequenzen aus dem Angriffskrieg der
Russen eine noch gravierendere
Konsequenz wäre der Beitritt der Ukraine
in die NATO darum wird es in Oslo gehen
wo sich ab heute die Außenminister des
Verteidigungsbündnisses treffen und
Florian neuhahn ist für uns vor Ort
florian ist man sich denn einig in der
Frage ob die Ukraine in die NATO soll
oder gehen da die Vorstellung der
Allianz schon noch auseinander
naja im Prinzip hat man diese Zusage
eigentlich längst gegeben nämlich 2008
schon vor 15 Jahren da gab es das
Versprechen der NATO an die Ukraine sie
irgendwann einmal aufzunehmen nur ist
daraus nie irgendetwas gefolgt auch
wegen der russischen Bedrohung jetzt ist
die Lage eine andere jetzt drängen
einige Länder darunter die Balken aber
auch die Briten auf eine konkretere
Perspektive für die Ukraine natürlich
für die Zeit nach dem Krieg aber sie
stoßen auch eben auf ein anderes Lage
die Skeptiker darunter eben auch die
deutsche Bundesregierung der deutsche
Bundeskanzler am nächsten NATO-Gipfel im
Juli in Litauen will man der Ukraine
einen konkretes Angebot machen eine
Perspektive vorlegen aber noch das sagen
auch erfahren die Diplomaten ist bis zu
einer gemeinsamen Linie ein hartes Stück
Arbeit vor der NATO
wie sind denn die Positionen zum
Drohnenangriff auf Moskau die Ukraine
sagt ja man habe nichts direkt damit zu
tun wäre das für alle Beteiligten ein
affron wenn es anders wäre
erstmal wollte man sich dazu heute kaum
äußern etwa hier in Norwegen die
Gastgeberin die norwegische
Außenministerin Anneken Wietfeld wollte
das gar nicht kommentieren weil die dazu
keine Informationen vorlegen aber es gab
eben doch dann noch eine Ansage eine
ziemlich deutliche sogar aus dem Weißen
Haus in Washington da sagte der
nationale kommunikationsdirektor für
Sicherheit und Kirby das ist ja eine
Zusage der Ukraine gäbe die gelieferten
Waffen nicht für Angriffe auf russisches
Territorium zu nutzen und darauf baue
man eben also man ist sich da in der
NATO doch ziemlich einig dass man eines
eben verhindern möchte dass dieser Krieg
über die Grenzen der Ukraine hinaus
eskaliert sagt Florian neuhahn vielen
herzlichen Dank für diese Einschätzungen
noch
also die NATO-Außenminister treffen sich
gerade in Oslo morgen treffen sich dann
über 40 europäische Staats- und
Regierungschefs in Chisinau in Moldau
zwischen beiden Hauptstädten liegen
gerade mal knapp 1900 km also keine
besonders große Distanz und auch bei den
zu behandelnden Themen gibt es eine
gewisse Nähe bei der informellen
Gesprächsrunde geht es darum auch mit
nicht EU-Ländern über Bündnisse
Kooperation und auch über die Sicherheit
des Kontinents zu beraten insbesondere
auch über die Sicherheit moldaus und
dazu gibt es tatsächlich Anlass genug
denn die Nähe des EU-Beitrittskandidaten
zu Russland ist aus unterschiedlichen
Gründen ein Problem wie ultra bei seiner
Reise durch die Republik Moldau erfahren
hat
die singt den bekanntesten Pop-Song
moldaus der in ganz Europa einen Sommer
lang zu hören war Europa der
Sehnsuchtsort vor allem für die junge
Generation aber seit dem Krieg herrscht
Angst
ich bete jeden Tag dass es keinen Krieg
gibt ich hoffe nicht dass die Russen
angreifen ich bin gegen Gewalt
moldas Hauptstadt Chisinau hat zwei
Gesichter wie das gespaltene Land die
jungen gut ausgebildeten Sätzen auf
Europa wie die Studentin Valeria sie
versteht dass viele ihrer Generation
gehen wollen
überall gibt es Korruption kein Bereich
des Lebens bleibt verschont wir sind
zwar so aufgewachsen kennen das aber wir
wollen so nicht mehr leben
seit dem Ukraine Krieg will auch Moldau
unabhängiger von Moskau werden die
Russen haben noch das Gaswerk in
Chisinau gebaut aber nun kommt die
Energie vor allem vom europäischen
Nachbarn Rumänien ist aber teurer die
Inflation in Moldau lag im letzten Jahr
bei fast 30%
sieht aus als wäre die Zeit stehen
geblieben vielen alten ist Europa egal
sie sagen früher und der russischer
Herrschaft ginge es ihnen besser
wir haben Arbeit wir hatten ein
Apartment wenn du krank wurdest zahlt
der Staat die Rechnung und deine Rente
war sicher
nur anderthalb Autostunden entfernt von
der Hauptstadt liegt Transnistrien eine
pro russische Enklave mit eigener Grenze
Moskau hat hier 2000 Soldaten
stationiert
wenn sie filmen sagt der Grenzsoldat
dann verschwinden sie für lange Zeit
1992 spaltete sich transistrien von
Moldau ab nun ist es Putins Brückenkopf
in den Westen
Moskau wolle die moldauische Kultur
zerstören sagen sie hier am Gymnasium
blagger einer der letzten Schulen die es
wagt ihre Tradition zu fliegen
[Applaus]
als der Krieg in der Ukraine anfing
hatte ich sehr viel Angst jeden Morgen
dachte ich die russischen Panzer kommen
wir können hier ja nicht weg wo sollen
wir denn hin Entschuldigung
in Moldau spüren sie Russlands Atem und
glauben die nächsten zu sein der morgige
europa-gipfel will dies verhindern
die Republik Moldau gehört übrigens zu
den 76 Ländern der Vereinten Nationen
die die Republik Kosovo nicht anerkennen
das Kosovo hatte sich ja 2008 als
unabhängig von Serbien erklärt dass die
Abspaltung wiederum nicht akzeptiert das
führt seitdem immer wieder zu
Auseinandersetzungen so ja auch in den
letzten Tagen und gestern hatten wir
hier darüber ausführlich berichtet wir
verstehen möchte was sich grundsätzlich
zwischen dem Kosovo und Serbien abspielt
der muss in der Geschichte weit
zurückgehen auch um Lösungen für das
jetzt zu finden der Appell der EU an
alle Beteiligten für Ruhe zu sorgen der
mag kurzfristig helfen langfristig
sicher nicht dazu gleich ein Gespräch
zuvor zeigt uns Britta Hilpert die
geschichtliche Ausgangslage
Kosovo sagen die Serben sei das Herz
Serbiens denn 1389 kämpfen
serbisch-orthodoxe Christen hier gegen
muslimischer Osmanen eine historische
Schlacht seitdem geht es für die Serben
hier um mehr als Territorium es geht um
Religion und ums Prinzip
besiedelt aber wurde das Gebiet
mehrheitlich von muslimischen Albanern
im 20 Jahrhundert ist Kosovo Teil des
viel völkerstaates Jugoslawien seit
Anfang der 90er zerfällt die Föderation
Jugoslawien in blutigen Kriegen das
Kosovo aber bleibt eine autonome Region
der Teilrepublik Serbien
die albanische Bevölkerungsmehrheit
strebt nach Unabhängigkeit die Serben
gehen gewaltsam dagegen vor es gibt
blutige Kämpfe Flucht Vertreibung und
Tod um eine humanitäre Katastrophe zu
verhindern so die NATO greift sie ab
März 99 ein und bombardiert Serbien
Russland protestiert im Juni 1999 wird
das Kosovo ein un-protektorat seitdem
soll die Kosovo Force kurz Kah vor den
Frieden zwischen den Volksgruppen
sichern auch unter deutscher Beteiligung
Rache aktuell gegen Serben im Kosovo
konnte die K vor nicht immer verhindern
2008 erklärt Kosovo seine Unabhängigkeit
die USA fasst die ganze EU auch
Deutschland erkennen das an andere wie
Spanien zögern bis heute Russland
traditionell ein Freund Serbiens und
China verweigernd Kosovo die Anerkennung
und UN-Mitgliedschaft sein Status in der
Weltgemeinschaft ist ungeklärt und die
jüngsten Unruhen haben auch einen Zellen
EU Friedensprozess zerschlagen das
Ringen von Ost und West um vormacht und
Einfluss im Kosovo geht weiter
und Hintergrund der jüngsten
Ausschreitungen sind Kommunalwahlen die
ethnischen Serben die hauptsächlich im
Norden des Landes leben boykottierten
die Wahl größtenteils dadurch sind
Kosovo Albaner mit sehr wenigen Stimmen
zu Bürgermeister gewählt worden doch wie
gerade gesehen der Konflikt liegt tiefer
also graben wir heute auch ein bisschen
tiefer mit Professorin Marie Janine
Kalix sie beschäftigt sich seit
Jahrzehnten mit Ost und
südosteuropäischer Geschichte ein
schönen guten Abend guten Abend wie
deuten sie denn die aktuellen
Auseinandersetzungen
ja es geht in der Tat um die Statusfrage
denn serbien hat Kosovo nicht anerkannt
und die Serben im Norden Kosovos
empfinden sich immer noch als
Staatsbürger Serbiens und wollen die
Kosovo Regierung nicht anerkennen und
auf der anderen Seite ist die Position
der Kosovo Regierung die auch die von
Serben besiedelten Gebiete natürlich
möglichst eng in ihre staatlichen
Strukturen integrieren möchte sehen Sie
denn legitime Interessen auf beiden
Seiten
man sieht durchaus legitime Interessen
auf beiden Seiten denn die Serben
möchten autonomie-rechte durchsetzen die
ihn schon vor über zehn Jahren
versprochen worden sind aber bis zum
heutigen Tag eben nicht umgesetzt wurden
auf der anderen Seite fürchten die
Kosovo Autoritäten die Regierung in
Pristina dass diese Rechte auch
missbraucht werden könnten dass es sowas
ein wie ein bosnien-szenario geben
könnte dass ich also eine autonome
Region abspalten könnte und dann diesen
sehr kleinen Stadt Kosovo praktisch auch
lahm liegt oder vielleicht sogar
zerschlägt jetzt wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe die Trennlinie zwischen der
eine ist schuld und der andere ist
unschuldig die ist eben nicht ganz so
klar aber wem nutzt denn dieser Konflikt
politisch
es gibt in beiden Hauptstädten in
Belgrad und Pristina nationalistische
Führungen die diesen Konflikt benutzen
um populistisch zu mobilisieren und die
ist natürlich für den eigenen Macht
Erhalt und auf diesem Wege letztlich
auch versuchen die maximalpositionen und
vielleicht auch ein Teil der legitime
Interessen durchaus durchzusetzen
allerdings nützt es natürlich niemand
wenn man versucht Interessen mit Gewalt
durchzusetzen auch jetzt wie man gesehen
haben unter Angriff gegen NATO-Truppen
und unschuldigen Menschen die einfach
dabei stehen das richtet immensen
politischen Schaden an und dieser
Schaden betrifft in der Tat beide Länder
wenn sie von Schaden sprechen welche
Versäumnisse sehen Sie denn bei den
internationalen Partnern also Russland
der USA aber vielleicht auch der EU
der Kosovo-Konflikt ist 1999 als die
NATO interveniertheit letztlich nicht
gelöst worden der Konflikt ist
eingefroren worden die ohne Resolution
1244 die diesen Konflikt beendet hat es
widersprüchlich wie auch das Völkerrecht
insgesamt widersprüchlich ist es wurde
nämlich auf der einen Seite den Albanern
im Kosovo sogenannte Selbstregierung
also mit anderen Worten auch ein eigener
Staat versprochen auf der anderen Seite
aber schützt die Resolution und schützt
das Völkerrecht die territoriale
Integrität und Souveränität von Staaten
also Serbiens und das heißt dass ich
beide Seiten mit guten Gründen auf ihre
maximalen Position zurückziehen können
einfach weil natürlich beide Prinzipien
überhaupt nicht zusammenpassen zuletzt
hatten sich Kosovo und Serbien ja unter
eu-vermittlung darauf verständigt die
Beziehungen zu normalisieren ist das
dann jetzt ein Trugschluss
nein der Vorschlag den EU gemacht hat
ist ein sehr pragmatischer Vorschlag
weil er ja gerade versucht diese beiden
scheinbar unvereinbaren Positionen unter
einen Hut zu kriegen und die Lösung
sieht so aus dass die beiden ihre
Beziehungen normalisieren unterhalb der
Schwelle der internationalen Anerkennung
das heißt man könnte diplomatische
Beziehungen aufnehmen man könnte alle
möglichen praktischen Probleme lösen
Serbien würde nicht länger den Wunsch
Kosovos boykottieren in die
internationalen Organisationen
aufgenommen zu werden und so weiter der
Vorschlag ist an sich gut aber es auch
unkonkret und vor allem in der Umsetzung
umstritten jeder liest so ein bisschen
hinein was er möchte zum Beispiel in der
Frage der Autonomie Rechte für die
Verben da glauben die Serben im Norden
Kosovos rauslesen zu können dass sie
eine eigene Körperschaft mit einer
eigenen Regierung bekommen während die
Regierung im Kosovo eben da hinein liest
dass es letztlich nur um eine
gemeindliche Selbstverwaltung geht Frau
Professorin sie sind ja auch
politikberaterin also was wäre denn ihr
Rat an die politischen Verantwortlichen
unter welchen Voraussetzungen kann es
zwischen Serbien und Kosovo Ruhe geben
ich glaube ich kann in jedem Moment Ruhe
geben in dem Moment wo die politischen
Führungen vor Ort bereit sind sich auch
in die Position der anderen das
Gegenübers hineinzuversetzen es geht da
letztlich um Fragen die praktischer
Natur sind und die man leicht lösen
könnte die aber symbolisch aufgeladen
sind und die letztlich diese symbolische
Aufladung ja mit dem Problem selber gar
nichts zu tun hat also die Lösung liegt
eigentlich auf dem Tisch die
Staatengemeinschaft steht bereit Hilfe
zu leisten nicht zuletzt auch durch den
EU Integrationsprozess und umso
unverständlicher und bedauerlicher ist
es dass es jetzt zu dieser Gewalt
Eskalation gekommen ist sagt Professorin
kalik vielen herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzungen heute Abend bei uns im
heute journal sehr gerne
und wir machen weiter mit Nachrichten
der sogenannte islamische Staat hat
heute möglicherweise einen Rückschlag
erlebt Hannah und zwar hier bei uns in
Deutschland ja ganz genau bei einer
großangelegten Razzia hat die
Bundesanwaltschaft sieben mutmaßlich
Unterstützer der terrormiliz islamischer
Staat festnehmen lassen den vier Frauen
und drei Männern wird zur Last gelegt
online Spenden gesammelt zu haben und
damit inhaftierte is-anhänger in Syrien
zu unterstützen insgesamt durchsuchten
mehr als 1000 Einsatzkräfte über 90
Objekte in mehreren Bundesländern
ab morgen startet ein neues Bau
Förderprogramm für Familien mit
niedrigen bis mittleren Einkommen wer
einen klimafreundlichen Neubau kauft
oder baut kann künftig einen günstigen
Kredit der Förderbank KfW erhalten laut
Bundes-
das Bundeskabinett hat eine Fortsetzung
der Bundeswehreinsätze im Libanon und in
Bosnien-Herzegowina beschlossen vor der
Küste des Libanons sind bis zu 300
deutsche Soldatinnen und Soldaten an der
blauhelmission unifill beteiligt unter
anderem um Waffenschmuggel zu verhindern
bei der EU-Mission in
Bosnien-Herzegowina sorgen bis zu 50
deutsche Soldaten dafür die Stabilität
in dem Balkan dann zu sichern beide
Einsätze sollen bis Ende Juni 2024
verlängert werden der Bundestag muss dem
noch zustimmen
das Leiharbeiter weniger verdienen als
die Stammbelegschaft obwohl sie die
gleiche Arbeit leisten das ist gängige
Praxis und rechtens das hat heute das
Bundesarbeitsgericht in einem
Grundsatzentscheidung bestätigt die
geltenden Tarifverträge in der
Leiharbeit widersprechen nicht dem
EU-Recht begründeten die Richter weil
Arbeitnehmer sein gesetzlich ausreichend
abgesichert denn sie würden fortlaufend
bezahlt auch wenn sie gar nicht
eingesetzt sein das gleiche die
schlechte Bezahlung aus
für den Kampf gegen Rechtsextremisten
rechtsradikale gegen Faschismus braucht
es Mut und Zivilcourage aber
selbstgerechte recht in die Hand nehmen
und Gewalt anwenden dieser Überzeugung
wurde heute Einheit geboten denn so der
Richter auch ein gewalttätiger Nazi ist
durch seine Taten nicht vogelfrei und
die Bundesanwaltschaft ergänzte es gibt
keine gute politische Gewalt angeklagt
waren eine Frau und drei Männer wegen
brutale Angriffe auf tatsächliche oder
vermeintliche Neonazis und
Mitgliedschaft einer kriminellen
Vereinigung gestützt hatte sich die
Anklage hauptsächlich auf einen
Kronzeugen aber nicht nur das führt
jetzt zu Diskussionen sondern auch das
Sachsens Ermittler nicht mit gleicher
Härte gegen Rechtsextreme vorgehen
würden über das Ende des Prozesses
man muss es wirklich einmal wirken
lassen
es ist ein Gerichtssaal kein Popkonzert
und die Frau hinter dem leeren
Aktenordner ist kein Rockstar auch wenn
es so klingt
minutenlang hält der Applaus für die
Angeklagte von den Zuschauerbänken das
Gericht brauchte fast 100 Tage um sich
ein Bild von Lina eh zu machen und von
der Szene die sie umgibt eine
linksextreme Szene die nun im
Gerichtssaal ausgeleuchtet wurde der
Prozess vor dem Oberlandesgericht in
Dresden hat gezeigt die Hemmschwellen
sind dort offenbar gesunken und das
zeigt ja dieses Urteil was ich ja damit
auseinanderzusetzen hatte dass
körperliche Gewalt gegen politisch
anders denken da eingesetzt wurde die
Gruppe hat rechtsextreme angegriffen
mehrfach gezielt geplant als kriminelle
Vereinigung die Opfer erlitten
Verletzungen manche auch schwere von den
15 Verdächtigen die Ermittler insgesamt
zur Gruppe rechnen sind manche auf der
Flucht Leben im Untergrund und nähren
somit eine Sorge Menschen die abtauchen
die endgültig abtauchen die im
Untergrund verschwinden die neigen dazu
radikalisieren dann kommen wir glaube
ich in eine Phase wo man nicht mehr von
einer kriminellen Vereinigung ohne
weiteres sprechen kann dann könnte es
auch schlimmer werden von Terror redet
Sachsens Innenminister noch nicht fünf
Jahre und drei Monate für Lina e
Haftstrafen auch für die anderen das
Publikum im Saal zeigte sich geschockt
und wütend Fascho Freunde so rief jemand
drinnen zur Richter Bank das Lina eh vom
Staat bestraft wird wo sie doch Nazis
angegriffen habe das können viele nicht
verstehen der Politologe schon ein
Gedankenspiel
wenn wir jetzt eine Anschlagsserie gegen
gegen Linksextremisten von
Rechtsextremisten umgekehrt hätten dann
das wenn wir das ganze jetzt einfach
einmal umkehren dann müssten die die
Linksextremisten ja auch erwarten können
dass der Staat sie gegen
Rechtsextremisten schützt natürlich gibt
es noch eine andere Sicht auf den Fall
eine ganz andere die Sicht der
Verteidigung die am Abend Revision
ankündigt wir bleiben bei unserer
Einschätzung dass das Vorgehen
insbesondere der Bundesanwaltschaft in
hohem Maße politisch motiviert ist wir
bleiben bei unserem Vorwurf dass die
Ermittlung einseitig geführt wurden sind
wir bleiben bei unserem Vorwurf dass die
Verurteilung im Wesentlichen auf
Hypothesen und Mutmaßung und weniger auf
handfesten Beweisen beruht die Strafe
Muslima eh nicht sofort antreten sie
kommt also vorerst frei trotzdem wird
das Urteil noch ein Nachspiel haben die
Szene will in den nächsten Tagen auf die
Straße gehen in vielen deutschen Städten
wie heute Abend zum Beispiel in Dresden
die Polizei rechnet bundesweit auch mit
Ausschreitungen
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft und mit
der Hanna die Inflation in Deutschland
ist im Mai ein weiteres Mal gesunken
bleibt aber dennoch auf einem hohen
Niveau von 6,1 Prozent das zeigt die
vorläufige Schätzung des Statistischen
Bundesamts fragen wir nach bei Frank
Bethmann im April lag die Teuerungsrate
noch bei
7,2%. wie groß ist die Hoffnung dass es
mit diesem Abwärtstrend jetzt immer so
weitergeht die Hoffnung ist da dass sich
der Preisauftrieb allmählich abschwächt
Benzin und Heizöl etwa wurden günstiger
wobei die Betonung auf allmählich liegt
der Weg zurück zu normalen Preisen zu
einer Inflationsrate die so um die 2%
liegt wird ein langer sein das sehen wir
insbesondere an den Nahrungsmitteln die
mai zwar weniger stark als noch im April
zulegten aber sich immer noch um 14,9%
verteuerten ähnliche Entwicklung bei den
Dienstleistungen ein weniger starker
Anstieg jedoch immer noch einer von
viereinhalb Prozent
die Richtung stimmt also für Entwarnung
sei es aber noch zu früh sagen die
meisten Ökonomen warum gibt es da
dennoch Vorbehalte eine gute in einigen
Bereichen bleibt der Preisdruck weiter
hoch Pauschalreisen verteuerten sich
beispielsweise enorm und mit Blick auf
die anstehende Urlaubssaison und der
Erwartung dass viele Deutsche dann doch
trotz knapper Kassen auf Ihren Urlaub
nicht verzichten wollen fürchten
Experten da könnte noch was kommen die
Inflationsrate könnte sich im Sommer
möglicherweise noch mal in Richtung 7%
bewegen dürfte sich im
Jahresdurchschnitt so zwischen fünf und
sechs Prozent einpendeln die Teuerung
bleibt so mit Thema auch über das Jahr
2023 hinaus vielen Dank Frank für diese
Einordnungen
ja und nicht nur die Inflationsrate ist
gesunken auch die Arbeitslosenzahlen
sind zurückgegangen allerdings weniger
stark als normalerweise im Monat Mai
laut Bundesagentur für Arbeit sind
aktuell 2 Millionen
544.000 Menschen ohne Job das sind
42.000 weniger als im April aber
284.000 mehr als im vergangenen Jahr die
Arbeitslosenquote sinkt auf 5,5%
jetzt der Blick auf die Lottozahlen an
diesem Mittwoch die lauten 22 30 35 39
41 45 Superzahl 6
50 Tage vor Beginn der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft der Frauen in
Australien und Neuseeland steht der
vorläufige Kader der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft fest Bundestrainerin
Forst Tecklenburg setzt für das Turnier
vor allem auf bewährte Spielerinnen der
EM darunter Kapitän in pop
Außenverteidigerin Giulia Gewinn fehlt
dagegen nach zuletzt langer
Verletzungspause verärger zeigte sich
Forst Tecklenburg über den FC Bayern
München weil der Club seine Spielerinnen
nicht rechtzeitig zu Beginn des
Trainingslagers abstellen
am 24.07 geht's los gegen Marokko
ja und gegen 0:25 Uhr hier meldet sich
Wulf schmiese mit unserem heute journal
Update das war's von uns wir sehen uns
morgen wieder machen sie es gut wo auch
immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Wetter
ja morgen beginnt der meteorologische
Sommer und der temperaturtrend von
Leipzig der zeigt uns dass es jetzt auch
erstmal früh sommerlich weitergeht also
es sind keine großen Temperatursprünge
oder gar Regen in den nächsten Tagen in
Sicht außerdem sehen wir die recht
großen Unterschiede zwischen den Tag und
den Nachttemperaturen nachts ist es
teils noch einstellig tagsüber steigen
die Werte dann aber auf um 25 Grad denn
im Moment haben wir es mit diesem Hoch
Viola zu tun dass uns diese stabilen und
vielen sonnigen Tage beschert morgen
allerdings schummelt sich da eine
schwache Kaltfront in den Norden des
Landes die wir zwar keinen Regen bringen
aber doch richtige Wolken und die
reichen schon in den Frühstunden der
Nacht den Norden des Landes sonst ist es
oft klar und dabei sinken die Werte auf
13 bis 6 Grad diesen kühlen Tagen steht
in diesem kühlen Nächten stehen die
warmen Tage gegenüber meist gibt es 20
bis 28 Salat am Oberrhein dazu gibt es
trockene Luft also es ist nicht schön
und gut aushaltbar im Nordwesten da ist
es allerdings deutlich kühler mit 14 bis
19 Grad das liegt dort vor allem an den
rechtdichten Wolken die die
Sonneneinstrahlung dämpfen und an dem
lebhaften Seewind der hinter der
Kaltfront auf Nordwest dreht aber sonst
ist das ein Tag für Sonnenliebhaber
nachmittags lockert ist auch im Norden
wieder auf und abends gibt's aus den
Alpen mal ein einzelnes Gewitter und bei
diesen sonnigen und auch warmen
Aussichten bleibt es in den nächsten
Tagen das ganze hält sich mindestens bis
zum Wochenende damit wünschen wir noch
einen schönen Abend